he won't stop until he destroys half the  universe everything you know everything  you love  it will all be gone together  we can stop flannels  [Music]  you don't want to trade him  but we were  [Music]  [Music]  the entire time I knew him he only ever  had one call  to wipe out half the universe if he gets  all the Infinity stones she can do it  with the snap of his fingers just like  that tell me his name again Santos  [Music]  we got one advantage  she's coming to us  we have with Dennis once so that's what  we use  [Music]  let's talk about this plan dears I think  it's good except it sucks so let me do  the plan and that way it might be really  good  Wow  the end is near  [Music]  half of humanity will still exist  perfectly balanced  as all things should be  I hope they remember you  [Music]  I'm Peter by the way dr. strange Oh  using your made-up names then I am  spider-man  you